now if you've ever been at the exhibit
hall of the Convention Center here in
San Diego you know that it's all about
the swag and I'm on a mission today to
find out what is the most expensive
thing you can buy a comic-con
what is the most expensive thing you
have in your shop here I'd say the titan
class Metroplex transformers it's one
hundred and sixty two bucks and it's
awesome what is the most expensive thing
you guys sell currently right now it's
two deluxe Chogokin Mazinger Z its
retail is three hundred seventy-five
dollars I bet you there are more
expensive things here at the con what do
you think they might be they're copies
like movie prop replicas of some sort
it's a good idea let's go looking for
those we have production quality
uniforms here at a Novo's one of the
items that we have here is the
next-generation outfit it is replicated
exactly how they did it in the show we
actually has the same manufacturer that
makes it the Baldrick or the sash item
altogether that item goes for
approximately around $2,300
but it's not the real deal it's close to
the real deal I think I want to go try
and find the real deal if you're not
familiar with mondo mondo is an Austin
Texas company they came out with a
brilliant idea let's hire the top
contemporary artists to do brand-new
movie posters for old classic films so
they got do Struzan to do Frankenstein
and they hired me to do King Kong and
how much did you sell this for $18,000
$18,000 this is Harrison Ford's whip
from the Indiana Jones movie no way can
I touch it
okay I'm gonna try this
it feels like Harrison so so can I guess
how much this costs going take again
$10,000 a little bit higher than that
higher okay 20,000 mmm a little bit more
you want me to give it to you 75,000
75,000 dollars for the whip from Temple
of Doom okay so this is actually the
most expensive thing that we have on our
stand today
this is Sigourney Weaver's flamethrower
from alien come on guess well you said
it was more than 75 so eighty five
thousand ninety five thousand dollars
issue I think I might have just found
the most expensive thing at San Diego
comic-con 2013
what do you have for me well what I have
here is Action Comics number one the
first appearance of Superman from June
1938 Superman celebrating his 75th
anniversary this year and here we have
his first appearance in 5.0 condition
the price $600,000 $600,000 and that's
this comic right here so I mean this is
really impressive but is it really the
most expensive thing you have I'm glad
you asked that because you know there's
a rivalry a friendship and a rivalry
between Batman and Superman and Batman
never likes to be outdone by Superman
and he's not gonna be outdone today
because we have Detective Comics 27 is
the first appearance of Batman this
one's a little higher grade than the
action comics and it's worth six hundred
and sixty thousand dollars six hundred
sixty thousand dollars for this comic
book here and together this is over a
million dollars with just two comics how
does it feel to have that in your hands
right now it's really magical
I've loved comic books since before I
could even read so do I be able to deal
in this stuff and make people happy with
it and buying sound and best it's it's a
dream come true